- I think our audience and
demographic is really sort
of like I think we're expanding a lot.
- Now this might be crazy, a crazy idea
but what if we did it
(grumbling)
what if we just changed the name
from buzzfeed to birdfeed.
Dereck are you okay?
- Yeah
(upbeat music) (grumbling)
- Profits
- Hey you know what, I
think you guys got this.
I think you guys are
really onto something.
I'm just going to- I gotta run to a thing
- Okay Dereck yeah,
- That I gotta be at so.
- I feel good about this
- You feel good that's great
- Yeah, alright
- That's awesome you guys are-
You guys just do your thing
- Okay
(upbeat music)
- Hey Dereck, how's it going?
- Alex, great how are you?
- I need those reports
by the end of the day.
- Okay, yeah I'm going to just, okay
(upbeat music)
- Yeah, this is good,
this is good. Good for me.
(door slams)
(flatulance)
- No I can't, no I can't,
I can't, no I can't
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
(upbeat music)
- How are those reports doing Dereck?
- They're great, they're on their way.
- Hey, how you doing? No go ahead.
No please, please after
you, yeah, great, awesome
- Fuck, motherfucker, shit.
Hey no, I was just - You're
good, you're good, okay.
- Yeah, yeah, fuck that fuck that yeah.
I'm gonna do it. I'm gonna
fucking- I'm gonna fucking do it.
I'm gonna fucking do it.
- How are those reports coming Derck?
- Can I take a shit alex?
- Okay.
(upbeat music)